of national security and cyber security
among his numerous responsibilities mr
marcus led the department's response
to the zika and ebola outbreaks a
relevant and timely
experience that he will bring to dhs
during this covet 19 pandemic
earlier in his career mr america served
as senate confirmed u.s
attorney in california
the national president of the fraternal
order of police
enthusiastically endorsed mr mjorkis and
i quote
his professionalism integrity and
commitment to just and fair enforcement
of the law
makes him an ideal candidate to lead the
department
mr mayarkas has pursued criminal
wrongdoers and
has protected the rights of the innocent
with indefatigable
vigor his work reflects all that is
right
in government mr mayarkas is an
outstanding nominee to the secretary to
be secretary
of homeland security his experience
qualifications deep expertise and
integrity
will serve our nation well in this
important and challenging position
steady leadership at the department of
homeland security is sorely needed today
i urge my colleagues to expeditiously
confirm mr mayarkas
so that he can serve as next secretary
of homeland security
today we'll get a chance to vote on mr
mayarkas i sin
sincerely hope that the republican
members of the senate judiciary
committee
will allow us to set the stage for a
hearing as quickly as possible
for our next attorney general mary
garland so much is at stake
the national security of the united
states should be a higher priority than
any
any partisan consideration mr president
i yield the floor
president the senator from louisiana
mr president um i want to talk about two
topics today first i want to
address the issue of immigration uh my
good friend
senator durbin um is uh
is is very articulate and and he is uh
almost an expert on this issue and i
appreciate his comments
i i want to just give you my perspective
of immigration because it's so important
this is not why i came down here today
mr president
i love legal immigration i think most
americans do
louisianians love legal immigration
uh welcome and and and i say that with
great confidence because every year
the american people invite over a
million
of our world's neighbors to become
american citizens
in a legal manner we are we are very
welcoming
in this country we invite more people to
become
citizens in america than any other
country in the world
and and and i'm flattered that people
want to come here
i mean other than someone living in
north korea
when's the last time you heard of
somebody trying to sneak into china
people want to come to america and i
just i'm so proud of that fact
i don't believe in legal immigration
some of my colleagues not not through
the chair senator devon but some of my
colleagues
think that vetting people at the border
is racist
i don't i think it's prudent every
country
every country does it um
we respect the rule of law in this
country and illegal immigration
is illegal duh i mean
um if you don't like the legal
immigration or the
the immigration laws one should change
them
in the meantime we have to to follow the
law i'm not real crazy about traffic
cameras
um i think in many cases they're
designed to
just raise money but uh
i i obey them and when i get fined i pay
the fine it doesn't happen often now
but uh i do it um
well this country needs a an immigration
system that that
looks like somebody designed it on
purpose it does
i think the american people deserve that
and
i would love to work with senator durbin
i'm not really interested in nibbling
around the edges i'm not real interested
in piecemealing it
i'm not really interested in some sort
of widespread amnesty
i think i think we ought to sit down
we all ought to take our meds and sit
down as adults
and and senators in good faith as all
senators are
and try to tackle this problem in a in a
global way
but i just wanted to make it clear this
is speaking for me personally i learned
a lot from listening to senator durbin
as i always do
i'm a steadfast believer in illegal
immigration
but i adamantly oppose illegal
immigration
i think it's dangerous i think it's
unfair
especially to those uh people across the
world who have
have waited in line patiently
and followed the immigration laws of our
country
now let me switch topics
one of the good things about politics
and government mr president you've
probably had this experience is that you
meet
you meet so many interesting people and
everybody's interesting in his own way
i've met people who are
more famous than wise i've met people
who are more wise than
famous and i've met people who are both
famous and wise
and one of the latter is what i'd like
to talk about today
it's a gentleman by the name of pat
shingleton
um his name may not be famous here it is
back in louisiana
but i can assure you that his virtues
are
um i want to honor the work of pat
shingleton today
pat is a baton rouge meteorologist
but he's also a long time
fixture in our community
uh he is retired i think his last
broadcast was friday night
he has worked for 45 years mr president
uh that's probably older than you
mr president he's been reporting
and trying to predict and he has
predicted the great accuracy of the
weather
in the baton rouge metropolitan
community for 45 years
but pat's experience covers a whole lot
more than being a meteorologist
though he's one of the best i've ever
seen in that regard
during his nearly half century of
reporting
the weather pats not only covered more
than 500
storms and hurricanes but he's also
hosted
we play baton rouge a local game show
the fifth quarter a sports show
hotline after dark a local talk show
where his guests
and i'm gonna quote here mr president
run the gamut
from champion bodybuilders to beer
brewers
to duck collars we're very diverse
people in louisiana
pat has a warm heart and he cares
for the state and the baton rouge
community and that's that's been on
display for a lot of years mr president
i'm not telling uh
my people back home anything they don't
already know
um pat's especially well known
for for being chairman of wbrz
wbrz channel 2 in baton rouge a
prominent local station
where pat has worked for so long pat has
worked hard as chairman of that
that stations pats coats for kids
pats coats for kids and uh
this program has unfortunately we we
have
we have children in america and in
louisiana
who who are hungry and cold
uh you can't learn when you're hungry
you can't learn when you're cold
pats delivered hundreds
of thousands could be in the millions
for all i know
of coats to kids whose parents
can't afford to keep them warm in the
winter
he's also created the quote philip
prescription for the needy project
and he started baton rouge st patrick's
day parade the wearing of the green
it's called which he continues to
coordinate
every single year pat's final broadcast
took place friday night
as i mentioned january 29th
uh that does not i can assure you
knowing pat singleton that does not
mark the end of his service to the uh
to the people baton rouge i can
i can say that with with great
confidence
i predicted pat will continue to
contribute as a
community community advocate as a as a
spokesperson at wbrz
i predict he'll continue to champion all
the charity projects that he's
spearheaded for so many years
now when asked about his retirement pat
said and i'm going to quote i think
we're all giving hope we're all given
a whole bunch of heartbeats
we're all given a whole bunch of
heartbeats pat
said and god gives us these heartbeats
to do something
good uh what an elegant way
of putting it pat's used his heartbeats
pretty well on my judgment he's got a
lot more to go
uh but he's done it for the good of our
state
for the good of the baton rouge
metropolitan community
and he's done it in the newsroom and
he's done it outside the newsroom
pat says he's going to spend extra time
with his family
good for him he's earned it especially
his uh
his one-year-old grandchild look
we're uh we're going to miss his guiding
hand
through louisiana's irreverent weather
patterns
we may have to draft him back on a few
occasions
but i want to wish him a joyful
retirement
to soak in all the the perks of being a
grandfather
pat thank you thank you for your hard
work for the people of baton rouge
thank you for your giving so much to the
people of louisiana
for all of these 45 years
you're a good person and you're a fine
american
god bless you and your family thank you
mr president
i suggest sir the absence of a quorum
i i withdraw that i would withdraw that
suggestion i think i'd rather just uh
yield mr president
president senator from michigan mr
president
uh i rise today in support of pete
and his nomination to to lead the
department of transportation
whether it's rebuilding our crumbling
roads
and bridges maintaining our leadership
in the
global mobility race or improving
pipeline
safety there's no shortages no shortage
of challenges facing our
incoming secretary as a fellow
midwesterner and as a former officer
in the u.s navy reserve i can't think of
anyone more equipped to take on
this challenge than pete but the judge
he understands the need to revitalize
our
infrastructure because he's seen it in
our neighborhoods and
on our roads each and every day when he
served
as a mayor he has a unique understanding
of how the department can be a resource
to state
and to local governments and what can be
done to ensure that the
federal government supports those states
and local governments and make sure that
need gets
addressed most effectively if we're
going to
build back better a partnership at each
level of government
will be absolutely vital having someone
at the helm who recognizes
that that relationship is so important
will be an incredible asset to the
department
i've also had several conversations with
secretary designate
who to judge on the auto industry which
is the very beating heart
of our manufacturing economy and as
the industry advances both towards
electrification and self-driving
technologies it will be critical that we
support these technologies
to make sure that they are safely
deployed and that they are deployed
here in the united states
we have an opportunity to save lives but
also to
create jobs and empower our domestic
auto industry
to take the moonshot for artificial
intelligence and
spur technological innovation
and i'm pleased that secretary
designated buda judge has committed to
working with us as we craft legislation
that establishes a
federal framework around these new
technologies and finally i'm excited to
work with secretary desi and buda judge
on improving
pipeline safety especially around
the great lakes we know that line five
under the straits of mackinac pose a
very serious threat to the great lakes
and the great lakes are not only an
economic driver and natural resource for
our country
they're literally in the dna of every
michigander
as a midwesterner and as a husband to a
michigan native who
was born and raised in traverse city
secretary designate buzajig
fully recognizes the need to protect
the great lakes i agree with mayor
pete's belief that he says quote
good transportation policy can play no
less a role
than making possible the american dream
i am proud to support pete buda judge's
historic nomination which has
already garnered bipartisan support and
i urge all of my
colleagues to vote for him
thank you mr president
senator from michigan mr president i
have six requests
for committees to meet during today's
session of the senate
they have the approval of the majority
and minority
leaders duly noted
senator from tennessee thank you mr
president
ahead of our votes today i want to echo
the concerns that have already been
voiced by many of my colleagues in this
chamber
regarding the nomination of alejandro
mayorkas
to be the secretary of the department of
homeland security
at this point we're all very familiar
with his
long legacy of service on behalf of the
people of the united states so i'll just
highlight one example
of value that he'll bring to the table
should the senate
vote to confirm him when he
served as uscis director during the
obama administration the inspector
general
was forced to investigate quote
an extraordinary end quote number
of internal allegations that mayorkas
was granting special access and special
favors
to wealthy eb-5 investor
visa applicants linked to influential
democrats when the ig took a closer look
at the visa applications
for three powerful chinese nationals in
particular
they came to the conclusion that if
mayorkas hadn't
intervened and i'm quoting the matter
would have been decided
differently end quote now mr president
this is something that we know is
inappropriate
we know that this is something for which
mr mayorkas should be held accountable
we know that this
is something for which he has not
been held accountable and here is what
he did he put his thumb on the scale
pressured his dhs colleagues
pressured his dhs colleagues to break
their
own rules and turn the law on its head
all because a few powerful friends
asked him to do it
he pressured others for the benefit
of some powerful friends and it is
all there for everyone to read
in the inspector general's report
and yet he was never
held accountable and yet
here we are being asked to support
his nomination to the president's
cabinet
there are plenty of policy differences
between myself
and mr mayorkas that have convinced me
i have no choice but to stand in
opposition to his confirmation
but the example i just cited in
particular gives me
additional serious concerns about how
his
influence would affect the integrity
of the agency just last week i joined
several of my colleagues
in a letter to the senior senator from
illinois asking him to exercise
his judgment as the incoming chairman
of the senate judiciary committee and
allow for a
second hearing so we could examine
mr mayorka's record thoroughly
because while i believe that the
president
has every right to assemble his cabinet
i also believe that the american people
have
every right to understand exactly
who is being put in charge of enforcing
our nation's immigration laws and
keeping
our borders secure enforcing
counter-terrorism measures and keeping
an eye on the country's
cyber security and the current nominee
never ha held accountable
for showing favor
to some friends in high places
that's not the way this is supposed
to be and i would urge my colleagues to
consider
what the american people the taxpayers
who are
footing the bill for every salary
that is given to every
individual working with the federal
government
what is the standard what do they expect
from their leaders thereby i oppose
the nomination and i yield my time and
notice the absence of a quorum
clerk will call the roll we're smalling
[Music]
[Music]
without objection mr president i come to
the floor today to support the
nomination
of pete buttigieg to be secretary of
transportation
we all know uh the nominee is mayor pete
a man who basically came onto the
national stage as
a midwest mayor who had lots of
enthusiasm for making investments
in america's future so today we're
considering his nomination to be
secretary of transportation
at a time when uh we need a lot of work
done on transportation
and in my opinion he's a young energetic
mayor who is going to help us
usher in a new era of transportation
that means there's going to be a lot of
bipartisan dialogue about how we get
there
but this job should not be
underestimated
in the importance that the
transportation sector and the
investments for the future
need that is that our transportation
system serves as a backbone of our
economy
and when it's not doing well the
consequential impacts
of that affect our economy it affects
how our businesses compete in a global
economy
it affects how people get to and from
work and it affects
their home life as well so it's a big
job that we have
and i know that this mayor and future
secretary of transportation
understands how big this challenge is
we've under-invested in our
infrastructure for decades in the past
10 years alone we've underfunded our
infrastructure needs by 1.5 trillion
dollars
the american society of engineers
estimates that we need to invest 5.6
trillion in our infrastructure
over the next two decades or the united
states stand to lose
about 10.3 trillion dollars in gdp
i know this because my state knows this
i think the presiding officer knows this
as well
if the transportation infrastructure
doesn't work goods and services don't
get through your ports they don't get to
their destination
and businesses choose other vehicles or
other avenues for the products to be
delivered
america needs to be competitive and the
american public also knows that poor
infrastructure
and the problems that they see in their
communities have to be addressed
whether that's concrete crumbling off of
bridges delayed trains
buses congestions railroads or
any of the many issues just this week a
highway
in california slid into the ocean
disrupting traffic along the famous
highway one
and this could be a delay for months i
know again the presiding officer
understands this
as well as the state of washington
mother nature doesn't always comply
with our transportation needs so while
these investments
and numbers may seem huge to people it
is what
this investment will enable that we need
to keep focused on
we need to focus on the fact that the
united states makes
and grows things and we need to get them
to their destinations
we need people to be able to get to
their place of employment
so we need someone at the department of
transportation who was enthusiastic
about taking on these challenges
and helping president biden administer a
new era of transportation
and the challenges that we face mayor
budage a harvard graduate
road scholar former united states
reservist who i believe
served in afghanistan also understands
the challenges
of small town mayors and the things that
transportation systems
and the impacts they can have he knows
the challenges we now face because of
coven 19
that there is a new burden on our
transportation system
because of the impacts of lost revenue
state departments of transportation
estimate
50 billion in lost revenues over the
next five years
airports have lost 23 billion because of
people no longer flying
transit agencies have lost an estimated
50 billion by the end
of 2021. so these losses will continue
to compound
until we find the best way to protect
our transportation workers
our travelers and to continue to help
with personal protective equipment
testing vaccines clear health based
protocols
to help return safety to our
transportation
system and public confidence that is one
of the reasons why we're fighting so
hard for this next package
of investments president biden took
decisive action by mandating that people
wear mass
which is a giant step forward in our
transportation system
i think there's more we can do and
hopefully our colleagues can work
together on that
the long-term revenue outlet for
transportation also
is changing and so it will be a long
time before its recovery
so i believe that that mayor moot pete
buduge is the right choice for this job
because he was mayor of south bend
he dealt with infrastructure where the
rubber meets the road
managing state federal and local
resources to help build infrastructure
in his community he also helped
facilitate public-private partnerships
for the dollars to go farther and
important models for future investments
in transportation
one of those projects the south shore
double track project
whose full funding grant agreement was
signed earlier this month
is like many other state and local
projects the south shore double track
demanded impressive coordination between
the federal
state and local governments to bring it
to fruition
buddage's smart street initiative also
shows he knows how to operate and
succeed in a current environment
and will be able to help communities
around the country replicate
the success that he had at south bend he
won't be the first mayor to be
the secretary of transportation but i
think we can say that when you have a
mayor in that job
they're going to pay attention to local
transportation
infrastructure investment to help our
communities continue to grow
and be competitive we have a major
opportunity i believe to now
deliver on infrastructure needs of many
of those communities
we should start immediately by talking
about infrastructure packages
and working on the transportation
infrastructure plan for the 21st century
because it's clear we have opportunities
this year with the surface
transportation programs expiring in
september
community every communities everywhere
are demanding
that we help work on these important
issues for their communities
but mayor budapest will also be called
on thinking about the new
eras of transportation and how we
maintain our competitiveness
he will have to think about issues of
ensuring safety with new autonomous
vehicle technologies and unmanned
aircraft he'll have to promote stronger
emission standards for
automobiles aviation and maritime
industries
he'll have to support the continued
growth of electric vehicle
infrastructure he'll have to make big
investments and gain changing projects
that will help us move freight more
cost-effectively through our nation
people will want to
know and understand what our reliable
passenger rail and transit systems
and the investment and bridges are going
to be for the future
so all of this are a big challenge but i
know that this
nominee is up to that challenge he did
well at the committee and making sure
that people
understood that he believes that those
challenges
need to be addressed for america
continue to move forward
from my perspective just in the state of
washington before
covid had really hit we saw 78 hours
per year of delayed traffic that is the
average commuter spent
78 hours in delayed traffic
a recent study in my state estimated
that washingtonians lost more than
7.4 billion dollars each year
in lost time and wasted fuel due to
congestion
deteriorated roads and safety problems
as america starts to head back to the
office no one wants to spend time
back in that world of congestion and so
we need to make critical investments
people in puget sound know that we need
to fix the west seattle bridge
they know in southwest washington that
the columbia river needs a new bridge
across
i-5 in eastern washington they know that
we need a north-south corridor
and in everett they know that the
trestle needs replacement if goods from
eastern washington are going to get to
the port of everett and out the door
all of these things are investments and
with them
come the structures of things like
at-grade crossings
crossings uh passenger rail
systems and safety that are huge
i believe uh infrastructure investments
that have not been quite
appreciated i was very pleased to get mr
boutique's commitment
during our session with him that these
things at great crossings
ports competitiveness and moving
products safely
should be a big priority for the future
the
lander street project in seattle which
was an investment of the new freight
program
was just a few blocks but literally
congestion for hours had stopped traffic
from getting
from i-5 to the port of seattle
the lander street in a lot of ways
represents what it
really is a bridge to the future a
bridge to get
people moving where they need to go and
the right investment being competitive
for the future
well we're going to face many more
delays if america doesn't remain
competitive
so i look forward to working with mr
butterjudge
on all of these issues he
also during the committee hearing
process
committed that we he will continue to
work with senator wicker and i
on the important issues of aviation
safety he committed to us that he
understood that aviation safety and the
faa need to continue to make
reforms i believe that if you want to be
the leaders in aviation you have to be
the leaders in aviation safety
and i think mayor budage gets and
understands that that will be a very big
job
of the department of transportation as
well so mr president
i enthusiastically support this nominee
i look forward to the type of focus that
he can give to the department of
transportation
this area of our government right now
needs to address the cova crisis it
needs to help us plan for a better
transportation system of the future
and it needs to understand that this
transportation infrastructure and
investment in these changes in these
sectors
of cars and planes and
passenger systems are all uh very
dynamic changing
industries and so our competitiveness
will be at stake as well
so i encourage my colleagues to support
this nominee
i'm sure we will hear a lot of
discussion from him and a lot of
bipartisan effort to help get our
transportation system fully funded
with that mr president i yield the floor
[Music]
ms baldwin
[Music]
foreign
uh
uh
[Music]
without objection thank you mr
aye mr president senator from
could we have the name
is there a sufficient second
there appears to be the yeas and these
are ordered
thank you mr president
[Music]
foreign
under the previous order the question is
on the nomination
the yeas and a's were previously ordered
the clerk will call the roll
miss baldwin mr barrasso mr bennett
mrs blackburn mr blumenthal mr blunt
mr booker mr boseman mr brawn
mr brown mr burr ms cantwell
mrs capito mr cardin
mr carper
mr casey mr cassidy
ms collins
mr coons mr cornyn
ms cortez masto
[Music]
mr cotton mr kramer
mr crapo mr cruz
mr danes ms duckworth
mr durbin ms ernst
mrs feinstein
mrs fisher
[Music]
mrs feinstein mrs fisher mrs gillibrand
mr graham mr grassley
mr hagerty ms hassan
mr hawley mr heinrich
mr hickenlooper ms hirono
mr hovind mrs
hyde smith mr inhale
mr johnson
mr kane thank you thanks for watching
mr kelly
[Music]
mr kennedy
mr king
[Music]
ms klobuchar
mr lankford
mr leahy
[Music]
mr lee
mr lujan miss lummus
mr mansion
[Music]
mr mr marky
[Music]
so
mr marshall mr mcconnell
mr menendez mr merkley
mr moran ms murkowski
mr murphy mrs murray
mr ossoff
mr padilla mr paul
mr peters
mr portman
mr reed mr
risch
[Music]
mr romney ms rosen
mr rounds mr rubio
mr sanders
mr sass
mr schatz
mr schumer mr scott of florida
mr scott of south carolina
mrs shaheen
mr shelby
miss cinema ms smith
ms stabenow mr sullivan
mr tester
mr thune
mr tillis
mr toomey mr tuberville
mr van hollen
mr warner
mr warnock
ms warren
mr whitehouse
[Music]
mr whitehouse mr wicker
mr wyden young
senators voting in the affirmative
bennett
blumenthal blunt booker
burr cantwell cardin
cornyn ernst feinstein
hirono johnson kelly
lujan menendez moran
murphy murray padilla
reed rosen shots
cinema smith white house
wicker and young mr brown mr brown
i senators voting in the negative
cotton cruise
[Music]
mr rounds mr rounds i
[Music]
aye
[Music]
mr barrasso mr barrasso i
mr portman mr portman aye
mr merkley mr merkley hi mr heinrich mr
heinrich
i
mr peters mr peters aye
[Music]
mr wyden mr wyden i
mr carper mr carper aye
mr cassidy mr cassidy no mr warner
mr warner aye mr king mr kane
i mr marshall mr marshall
no ms baldwin miss baldwin
i
[Music]
so
mrs gillibrand mrs gillibrand i
[Music]
ms warren miss warren i
mr kennedy mr kennedy i
uh
mr scott mr scott of florida no mr danes
mr danes i miss lomas
miss lummus i mr tuberville mr
tuberville
no mr sass
mr sass i
[Music]
mr king mr king i
mr mansion mr mansion i
[Music]
mr tester mr tester i
[Music]
mr boseman mr boseman
mr creamer mr creamer i
[Music]
mr ossoff mr ossoff
[Music]
mr leahy mr leahy aye
[Music]
ms duckworth ms duckworth
mrs hyde smith mrs hyde smith aye
mr durbin mr durbin
i mr sanders mr sanders
i mr coons mr coons
aye
so from there miss collins miss collins
i
[Music]
mr bozeman mr bozeman i mr paul
mr paul i
[Music]
so
mrs shaheen mrs shaheen
mr van hollen mr van hollen i
mr inhofe mr inhofe
aye
[Music]
my
uh
[Music]
mr brawn mr brawn i
mr graham mr graham i
mr shelby mr shelby
no mr grassley
mr grassley i
[Music]
so
[Music]
mr markey mr markey aye
mrs capito mrs capito i
[Music]
mr tillis mr tillis
aye
[Music]
uh
mr crapo mr crapo i
[Music]
you